Gráfica el par ordenado 6,-8 en el plano coordenado que se muestra
ese es el plano coordenado, el eje horizontal,
es el eje de las "x"
el eje vertical es el eje de las "y"
y la convención para cuando nos dan un par ordenado,
como este que se muestra acá,
es que, la primera coordenada es la coordenada "x" y la segunda coordenada pues va a ser la "y"
nos dicen que tenemos una coordenada "x" de 6
significa que vamos a contar 6 sobre el eje "x"
veamos 1...
vamos a escribirlo 1, 2
aquí tenemos 3 aquí tenemos 4, aquí 5
y aquí 6, el que buscamos
comenzamos desde el punto 0 el origen
0, 0
y nos movimos 6 lugares hacia la derecha
es esta parte de aquí, ahora la coordenada "y" es -8
significa que tenemos que desplazarnos
hacia abajo 8 lugares en el eje "y"
nos vamos al origen y voy a marcar cada dos lugares...
este es -2, este -3, aquí escribo -4, -5 y aquí -6
-7 y escribo -8 que es el que estoy buscando.
Entonces nos fuimos 6 lugares a la derecha
y ahora vamos a bajar
8 lugares hacia abajo verticalmente
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
aquí está, esta es la coordenada que nos piden
esto es la coordenada 6, -8 el punto
que nos pedían graficar
y también lo podemos hacer de esta manera, aquí arriba nos movemos 6 lugares
y aquí bueno dibujamos la línea sobre la que va a estar nuestro punto "x" y nos vamos en el eje "y"
vemos este -8 y ahí dibujamos otra línea horizontal
y donde se unan estas dos líneas es el punto que estamos buscando.
A mi como me gusta hacerlo
es primero moverme en el eje "x"
y de ahí entonces bajar o subir en el eje "y"